welcome to Eskimos factories are
flooding the US with two tons of
you
in the 1980s he formed the Medici cartel
one of the biggest criminal
organizations the world had ever seen it
supplied 70% of cocaine in America with
his money
Escobar created dozens of soccer fields
opened health centers built entire
neighborhoods from scratch Escobar is
also a shrewd businessman and knows he
needs popular support in his community
he builds football stadiums and schools
here in his hometown we came to the ends
justify the means as long as your ends
are good the means don't really matter
and it's interesting we're gonna see he
gives money to the poor but if anyone
gets in his way
this will happen to you if you come
against me police judges and politicians
and no exception
in 1989 Escobar's ruthlessness reached a
new level - silence - informers it was
one person he was looking for what he
did
yeah is they because the American
government wanted him extradited to the
US service prison sentence net and then
the Colombian government was on they
were hooking it's a good idea so this
guy stuck one in a mad one they start
throwing up everything in anything that
may be the end Georgie's police officers
everything here and then he said okay
don't come to the green again I will
survive years in prison yeah he Pablo
Escobar he said I'm gonna build my own
prison this is never happened in the
history of mankind yet he said I want to
build my own prison and I'm gonna stay
there sir five years yeah and then in
his prison in 1990 Escobar made a deal
he would surrender and serve a greatly
reduced term that cushy prison built
specially for him while the government
would once and for all killed the
extradition treaty with the US he
surrendered into a facility that was
really built by him controlled by him he
built in essence a country club with all
the amenities allegedly built in his
property under his specifications
it contained hiding places throughout
the buildings where he could hide money
weapons he put the soccer field
he had a great suite for a sell very
well furnished sitting
with his friends came in he was business
from the prison and you know in that
same prison he killed two of his poems
he chopped them into pieces and hundreds
of Colombian troops are hunting the
drugs man Pablo Escobar who escaped from
prison during a gun battle the
government was about to move Escobar
from a jail near the town of Medina said
he continued to control that became
trade the colombian president says our
NGO area said he would still refuse to
extradite suspected drug traffickers for
trial abroad after escobar escaped from
prison the colombian government created
the search bloc a special military task
force trained by the united states in
order to find them
the security forces were not the only
ones hunting for Pablo Escobar there was
also a death squad funded by the Cali
cartel
there's no junior cartel is yeah okay
there were the rebel because I was
working with communist soldiers as well
yeah what happened was he got the
communist soldiers and he paid them off
to go to I imagined someone going to the
they see the big you know the Parliament
is yeah and they keeping documents
they're gonna using his public school he
pays the communist rebels off they go
there with tanks and blow up the whole
place and burn the whole dock in this
awful yeah like footage rope tanks
they're going in is like someone driving
into saying that's how bad big that's
how powerful it was so no tank yeah and
these guys they hated the Communists
from a mistaken they had an issue with
the Communists
so the Cali cartel Pablo Escobar enemies
again caught I would describe a little
they form a death squad called los pepes
yeah people that are persecuted by Pablo
Escobar that's what stands for peppers
PEP OS and they start going on a mad
work they start killing all these
soldiers and
that stands for people persecuted by
Pablo Escobar every time they would kill
someone
this group basically turned the table in
Pablo Escobar they used his tactics to
combat him those people had a lot of
information on problem and along the way
they still also started providing
information and intelligence to the
combination police and advise the
authorities in general so they became
SoCo informants and in the end it will
fit this ended up playing a huge part in
the demise of Pablo Escobar because they
basically left with a long so they sent
two of their officers around to the back
side of the house
crow Martinez is instructing them hit
the location let's find out that's
probably the still take a chance on
losing one officer as he was running up
the steps tripped and fell which
probably saved his life because probably
the shot at him at that exact moment
when Pablo gets to the third level he
jumps out the window he and the
bodyguard and running across the roof
would be adjacent row house the
bodyguard jumps off the roof two police
officers engage him in a gun battle and
shoot him dead and Pablo heard two
gunshots and realized he was in
crossfire so he's trying to return fire
to the apartment he just escaped down
over the road house and he's also trying
to refer returned fire to the police
officers on the ground and they
basically haven't been cross fire and
Pablo Escobar is killed it's an actual
footage that's a picture on that roof
[Music]
Oh
you will escape even with
because he worked with the poor yet see
like loads like thousands came to his
piano yeah well basically you can see
his his end personally it just it just
makes you reflect and say and obviously
prob let's go yes you had a big
fortunate such a whatever may be and but
without reaction videos we don't just
make you know oh we're gonna do this and
so know this guy if you look at it's
like he's cute
they say thousands yeah maybe thirty
thousand people maybe more than that yet
and let me correct that
yeah the guy was supplying it but this
night indirectly killed thousands of
people
yeah he blew planes them yet building
now you need the others have a question
how could somebody like he had kids he's
looking at a daughter a son he was a
life today children yeah he blew up
likely he brought a bomb so close to the
the Prime Minister's house like that it
is a people were killed this kind of no
keep it down he was killing never I sent
up so he asked you the question why
would anybody come to that level of not
caring the selfishness his son in an
interview scene the guy was obsessed
with winning now when they will claim an
opening at home you know the fake money
he would actually hide that so just like
hey if he's losing the game you take out
of nowhere like the kind of obsessed
with winning this cycle so to me it
shows that what else one says in the
Quran those for example who make they
designs they're good yeah so this time
because of you know wanting to be there
be the man be in charge I have to be
there are etc it's me me me me me that
has come at the cost of thousands of
people dying and look at the humiliation
that he
to bring crack cocaine into the into the
US I'll tell you because as cocaine was
allowed to come in this was in the 1980s
this was a time Pablo Escobar reached
his peak because cocaine was coming in
and this is where people like made about
billion dollars used to make three
million a day there was a CIA just
jam-packed with drugs Pablo Escobar and
his lifestyle very very looked up to buy
a lot of young people a lot of the youth
especially obviously guys cuz you're
gonna have the image you're gonna have
the nice cars you have the women
throwing themselves at you you're gonna
have you know and drugs and all of these
things are becoming promoted etc in
society and if we look at people like
Pablo Escobar
they never have they never ever had a
limit they never ever had a thing where
they were like you know I'm content and
evidence of this program sisters if you
look at his life the amount of homes
that this guy owned in the hundreds in
different locations the amount of cars
your mother's money importing trees and
all of this nonsense you know why it's
literally because you don't find a sense
of contentment yeah so when you live
that sort of life think about your
favorite rapper that wants to be like
Pablo Escobar that is naming his album
after Pablo Escobar think about these
people how are they every single time
you see them they're wearing different
clothes they were in a different watch
they're always bragging about their what
their woman how it's always changing why
because they only find
contentment in these things so this sort
of lifestyle people can't keep up with
it and it will never bring you peace and
if you see how he ended up that's how
you will end up if you chase that so
glad we're talking about ending this
look he got cute
okay okay you pay for one person died
killed himself
yeah Martina's gonna finish over here no
it's not you think a lot you think god
almighty was greater loss he's just
gonna be like okay yeah he's just crated
off in vain no he's not you know he
hasn't Maxwell Isfahan says in the Quran
that to those who are you go into the
fire in the architects of solar I mean
is that when the flesh is burn Allah
says I will renew their face when they
taste the punishment again so you can
see Allah will do justice what did he
take from this life and you know Allah
nothing and you know what the amazing
thing about allah subhanaw taala is yeah
he always uses those people to prove
that this is not success just like at
the time of your own yes there was a man
called harmon if you read about him in
the quran he would literally go about
flaunting his jewels flaunting his
carriage is made of gold wood and
everything made of gold and literally a
line front of everyone made the earth
open up all of his possessions and his
belongings and himself fall into the
earth and the earth closed you know
people he's killed
so why do you think why do you think and
then why do you think is you said he's
buying all this stuff why is it
giving it to the poor he's trying to
renew his conscience yeah yeah that's
like the famous thing of best day you
see plugged in hands in your washing
machine I think the end these people
asked for this cause it shows you Cosmo
there's somebody got thirty billion
euros richest yet everything that he can
have he was not happy but if Allah wants
to put contaminant new you'll find a man
who's I'm telling you he has nothing is
living in a shed the happiness yet this
guy can't he would die to buy it so what
did well does it show that happiness
comes from it comes from Allah not from
material gain it sometimes we would
foliage we think I'm in control of my
happiness no you're not you're not
happiness comes from our love is those
who sacrifice this life those who
sacrifice the hereafter for this life
will lose both hey what did he gain what
did you gain you lost this life and
hereafter those who sacrifice this life
for the hereafter will get both people
watching they they might not be
practicing or they might be thinking you
know what this isn't going right when
this goes right then I'll go to the
Masjid yeah you're doing it the wrong
way you have to first correct your
relationship with Allah then with the
people there's an order if you just
switch off a fan you put your hand in it
yes it will stop you're gonna end up
harming yourself people want to get rich
quick
but what cost they've come to these
countries and there's a very important
thing they said we've come to and the
dollar and the pound but we've lost our
gems and jewels yes the gems and jewels
is memorials I think this culture
children obviously you know believing
their Dean yeah hope you guys a man if
it did I just wanted to know a
documentary coming soon we are looking
money is gonna be coming soon subscribe
to me and smile to general all right
guys what benefited always to go home
yeah and if you guys want to learn more
about Pablo Escobar feel free to share
gender you YouTube channels